i got asked what my best advice for
achieving success on the internet was
the other day
it got me thinking about where the
biggest competitive advantages lie
and i realized something consistency is
even rarer
than talent or enthusiasm think about
yourself
how many times have you had a burst of
enthusiasm for a side hustle you can't
sleep because you're always thinking
about it you watch every youtube video
on the internet
and you're totally submerged in 24 7
keenness this is
essentially every january 1st in the gym
or
final week before launching a new
business or
think to when you started a new project
and realized
that you actually have a natural talent
for it you pick up
ad optimization really easily in your
first class
or you start a podcast and discover that
making the conversation
flow well just comes naturally to you
these situations
come along less frequently than you
might think
but probably more frequently than you
might predict
the problem is they appear randomly
for all your competitors too everyone
else also
stumbles upon a natural capacity for a
new project
and enjoys the benefits of spurts of
enthusiasm a competitive advantage
is not an advantage if the rest of the
competition
has equal access to it another problem
is that
both talent and enthusiasm are only
fleetingly useful
talent might mean you can pick up ad
optimization
20 quicker than everyone else but
as you climb up the ladder you're now
competing with people
who can pick up things just as quickly
and they've been doing it for a decade
enthusiasm might mean you're super
excited to start your podcast and have
researched and organized all your guests
for the next month but after
three months when the plays have
flattened out your enthusiasm is
starting to wane
and you don't control when it comes back
in my experience consistency is the most
valuable
and least common trait of all doing
something challenging
and worthwhile at the same time every
day
or multiple times per week is incredibly
rare it's seen as the realm of
professional athletes
top flight musicians and zen masters and
this
is why consistency is the perfect
competitive advantage opportunity a
higher number
of your competitors will be talented or
enthusiastic
than consistent this means that simply
by not
stopping you will separate yourself
from everyone else imagine that there's
a particular
great filter which all people in your
industry encounter
a big barrier of discomfort perhaps it's
boredom perhaps it's demotivation
perhaps it's slow growth of revenue or
followers
let's say that after 150 weeks of
consistency
the average person in your industry is
really
starting to run out of gas and struggle
their talent and enthusiasm
have both been competed out by other
talented and enthusiastic people
it now becomes a battle of consistency
who can deal with that discomfort and
just
keep going inevitably some competitors
start to drop
off because it's hard and repetitive and
unrewarding
this is why not stopping separates you
from everyone else
consistency is hard and rare sometimes
in the back of your head you might hear
a voice that says
if it was meant to be it wouldn't be
this difficult i shouldn't be finding it
this hard
all my competitors seem to be coping
just fine in
my experience this is untrue everyone
finds consistency difficult they just
don't post
about unremarkable grinding because
there's no magnificence in turning up
every day as brian green says the moment
to moment
of almost anything you are doing is a
grind
it is only upon completion in reflection
when you can see the glory in atomic
habits
james clear asked the head of the
chinese weightlifting team
what sets the world champions apart from
everyone else the answer was simple
whoever can handle the boredom
of daily training the best forget
any ideas you have around consistency
not
being hard the discomfort is a feature
not a bug it's simply a case of dealing
with it
better than the next guy the ability to
be consistent
is getting more valuable as attention
becomes more scarce
and alternative options more abundant if
you're a
peasant in the middle ages it's an easy
decision to become a master woodworker
if the choice is between woodwork and
starving to death
in the 21st century you can gig
economy telegram chat tinder swipe your
way from
half-baked business to semi-launched
project
for an entire career fewer and fewer
people
will be able to consistently do one
thing
for long periods of time this is why
consistency
is the ultimate competitive advantage it
is becoming both
increasingly valued and increasingly
rare
at the same time a final advantage of
consistency
is that you're in control of it you
don't get to choose your talents
or your motivation level but
turning up every day is entirely within
your power
and by doing that you will develop
your talents and build motivation anyway
over time you will end up in a place
you're worthy of as charlie munger says
spend
each day trying to be a little wiser
than you were when you woke up
discharge your duties faithfully and
well systematically you get ahead
but not necessarily in fast spurts
nevertheless
you build discipline by preparing for
fast spurts
slug it out one inch at a time day by
day
at the end of the day if you live long
enough
most people get what they deserve it
takes
10 years to become an overnight success
just keep going and if it came easily
it wouldn't be worth anything anyway so
don't pray for talent or enthusiasm
pray for the strength to keep going let
me know what you think in the comments
below
and for more life lessons press
subscribe peace
[Music]
you